so we're here with the guardians
which is one of the search and rescue
teams here in the alps in italy we're in
a range called the dolomites and this is
where
on sunday a glacier collapsed sending
260
000
cubic meters of snow and rock and ice
down the mountain more than 300
kilometers an hour hitting the people
below what this team has been doing is
searching the mountain for any evidence
of those people so looking for clothing
for equipment and then when they see it
they can go down and retrieve it but
it's far too dangerous at the moment for
anyone to go up on those mountains uh on
foot so what they've been doing is
sending helicopter teams like this one
drone team dog teams as well to try and
look for evidence
now what they also have been telling us
is that climate change
has been very noticeable so they've been
seeing the ice melting it's much hotter
at the moment it was much warmer over
winter as well much less snow than
normal all of that making the ice much
more unstable and much more likely to
fall so the other thing that they're
aware of now is that there is a risk of
further avalanches further landslides as
well so all of this is in their minds